one of the most interesting things we
can perhaps david cameron's piece in The
Sunday Times so I'm interesting for lots
of reasons
quite a sort of speechifying piece with
a little tough rhetoric about so
standing up and standing short distorted
with the victims and the calling for a
response but it left you begging the
question really well you know what can
he actually do yes I don't know I think
this is one thing spam clear over the
weekend I mean as the stories about the
missile and Ukraine and so on has become
more and more really it's become gas
clear and ghastly I mean that the
details of body is being mistreated of
of people going through and stealing
people's belongings it as all of these
awful human stories have come out it
sort of Lee it's exacerbated the the
fact that there doesn't seem to be any
political response I mean maybe there is
no political response maybe David
Cameron can't think of one maybe nobody
can but but simply that hundreds and
hundreds of people should be killed and
all these politicians make statements
President Obama hearing or a major news
conference but there's no there's lots
of announcements about what has happened
yeah but very little about what ought to
be done about it
yeah Luton we do sort of thinking well
is your aim just to look tough here
moral leader against I mean President
Obama gave basically a sort of what
would ordinarily be a press spokesperson
yeah conference me said what America
currently knew but that shouldn't be the
president's job yeah and all this talk
of sanctions I mean if everyone doesn't
back together meanings of Japan in terms
of sanctions how worried is what she's
gonna be by this I wouldn't feel very
worried at all about this I mean it was
there was a window when this first
happened when it looked like this could
actually be led back in such ways to
actually be a problem for Putin in
particular I think that problem a were
that point may already
I think one of the big things about home
is it's a big challenge for Angela
Merkel the Germans have I'm back in the
hospital
we have pushed a more malleable line a
softer line towards Russia than some of
the other countries in the EU I mean
it's big moment as to whether the
germans are prepared now to say that
Putin has crossed a line and that the
sanctions have to be increased in that
way and then I think the other thing is
this is I think there's one set of
sanctions that really water Wladimir
future and that sanctions aimed at him
and his family I mean this is a man who
likes his creature comforts who likes
his wealth kissing him there I think
would be the thing that would draw the
would show him that the west where he
does me invested evil genius in a way of
what Putin has done with leaving the
crash site then moving in the
point-source he's crazy enough confusion
that he's trying to say well well you
can't prove it why is there evidence um
and by you know because he is playing by
completely different set rules to have
anybody else either
we're not never know I'm never gonna be
able to conclusively prove exactly
looking because that is now gone off to
Russia it's at all this and I think he
is he is just going to carry on doing
this saying well I didn't do it